before they walk forward
to realign with you
so it's like
you're trying to step around it's not
gonna work because they're walking
forward in your face stopping you and
then they realign and instead of getting
the character we expected steve versus
[ __ ] rum we're getting leroy versus
negan and this probably the first time
i've ever seen this matchup in my life i
was going to say the same thing i've
never commentated this i i've never
played this i used to play a little bit
of leroy before a lot of players stopped
and uh yeah this is i've never seen this
i'm looking forward to it
and you notice frison he'll use the
stick
well it seemed in the last two games he
used that stick very very quickly he
wanted to make sure he got that out and
never had it unused let's see if he does
that again in the first round i mean
it's common to just not want to die with
your resources so just use it as early
as possible
especially this is a one-time use thing
not like ready to get every single round
you might as well make use of it um so
yeah so
libra versus negan is an interesting
might have to say at least a negan i
think is such an underrated character in
this game uh normally people really play
them at the top level you see a white
honey take the character down to them
nice intro though the one one plus two
um but i don't think you don't really
see many people play the characters
interesting because you know people say
oh it's not fantastic he doesn't have a
homie move with negan he doesn't really
need one because stepping him is a
mix-up his dr his jabs will track one
way and it's down for one tracks the
other way which makes him a nightmare to
step if he's just playing a simple
poking game but as i speak uh frison
takes the first round very fast
very fast indeed
we're going to the wall as well this is
a great start here from prison the
neighborhood's really been working out
for him today oh you need to get up or
lagino
i think we may see some more that i mean
what just took my breath away was the
fact that he baited a big whiff punish
and he just absolutely smacked him for
even going for it oh nice oh
combo there down back four great start
here from prison round three
very very quick play again
oh
there's the game i think he wanted to
whip underneath they didn't work up a
nice step though in the background plus
two off axis does he know the combo yes
he does
okay get out before there beats the
hermit stands that can't pursue the plus
frames
oh nice parry there orbital
back one to interrupt ryzen looking
really good right now can you do a no
round brown
okay the spring casing up down 3-2 and
just like that prison takes the first
round three
rounds straight what a stop
what is going on today
this is crazy i love the way frison he
he didn't let him really get into any
rhythm of his okie at all he was he was
doing get get up kicks he was just
making sure that he wasn't stuck in a
vortex of having to deal with down back
to and the subsequent mix-ups it was a
really consummate performance i mean
that's got to say look i'm sure he's got
to go back to his [ __ ] round that was
that was insane he even parried the
shove like that can be quite jarring
when someone parries your shove i mean
the thing is is uh they sort of when
[ __ ] run was a huge problem people
sort of picked especially in pakistan
people would pick leroy as a counterpick
for the character the main reason being
if he goes for his charge up so you can
just know bring back to you parry a lot
of things he tries to go for the guard
break and also his punishment was pretty
good on [ __ ] rams that made him uh he
couldn't replay his game uh fantastic
the matchup is pretty much in leroy's
favor
um so maybe that's what he was thinking
going into this i'm going to try negan
instead it's not it's not the same but
negan account sorry lyra character can
still parry everything the weapon
doesn't really change anything so
the interest if he goes to the character
switch here i don't know what i do in
his situation
i think it's so difficult versus frison
if you even if you win your first game
he may switch to steve which is well
known to be one of the best thieves in
europe or has been over recent years
it's a it's a real battle i'd say this
is massively uphill now foreign let's
see what he does
steve as well also a good pick against
[ __ ] around because that's what downfall
to control the neutral space
um
it'll be interesting to see how he plays
this
yeah it's interesting now leeway versus
[ __ ] rum this is these are the
characters that terrorized
second seven throughout the years when
they first came out
made people uh
quit the game
my heart breaks to see these guys beat
the crap out of each other it really
does yeah
the thing is though no matter who wins
here we're all losers
nice nice dark prison but no punish is
aware i mean allegheny has been doing
that a lot the 3-4-4 uh that high has
been doing that last bit pre-telegraph
now no punishment 3-4 but gets the count
and hit nice runs up to this down back
to the shaolin punches
back nope punish
oh run up into background between just
like that is gonna take another round is
this four rounds straight it is it is
and i think and just to add to the
weight of of
various things on our laguna's shoulders
poland has some pretty good [ __ ] rams
tocus for example we've seen him before
very very strong [ __ ] man frison
would have seen all of this before we've
already seen it with some of his ducks
but he gets caught by that doesn't get
converted easy it wasn't a good ball
splat but then he just carries on he
plows right through him on the board for
allegheny i mean one thing i don't like
he's doing he's doing a lot of a lot of
three one down four that is launched
punishable in the stringing and you can
doubt the three one and they see more
people ducking that he shouldn't be able
to get away with that for three for free
oh but the other one orbital the trade
that works out for prison
i'm like four jet kick
three four four three four no punish
there from prison minus thirteen back
two three no duck on the string
this stage not necessarily helping
prison wasn't allowing him to move on
yeah
that's a combo that lira can only get on
the big boys very nice here great start
three three
oh my god the big strap string twice in
a row prison one right away from moving
forward did not lose his bracket right
now
nice block nice punch oh great step
there from prison
three four no punish again minus
thirteen
oh big whiff on the jet kick no punish
goes for the cane instead being quite
unfortunate with that
one plus two nice punishment with one
four but back nine one plus two is the
is the move of the day
one three four
and that's gonna be the game
the hermit four four
great start there from prison and he
moves forward in our lucid bracket
commiseration starting